A very interesting discussions this morning on
The David Pakman Show sub Reddit, where you can
join 26, maybe it's 27 now. Twenty six twenty
seven thousand other David Pakman show viewers,
David Pakman dotcom slash Reddit.
A few interesting posts. You know, I got a few
emails like this, and this is a post from Portland
hipster who said, David, why on earth would you
not tell Republicans not to vote in Georgia if you
can convince an already psychologically damaged
or duped Republican to not vote for more
destruction? Isn't that the morally correct thing
to do? In all likelihood, having a Democratic
controlled Senate would benefit these deranged
Republicans in material ways. So don't you have
a moral obligation to help get a Democratic
controlled Senate by any ethical way possible?
Doesn't that trump your principle of voting? No,
I don't think so. What I said earlier this week
and last week is one of the main one of the big
messages, the top level messages on this show is
engaging people in the political process. And part
of that is increasing voter turnout. And everyone
must vote. Everyone must vote. Everyone must vote.
And so because that's the big principle, what this
user is doing is engaging in a special pleading,
which is, well, yes, get more people involved,
vote, vote, vote. Except this time where by buying
into obviously false conspiracy theories that the
election is rigged and abandoning the principle of
increasing engagement, you might serve a greater
good. Right. The argument is, well, you know,
your argument, David, about more engagement
is generally good. But here, Democrats taking
the Senate would create so much good, it would
trickle down. It's justified morally this time
for you to lie to people and say, you know what,
Republicans, you're right, it's rigged and you
should stay home. This is exactly one of the
points I've been making. Just because I might
be able to justify it in this micro case, I'm
not going to abandon the macro principle. And
I don't think the left needs to. I don't think
the left you know, when I say, guys, listen,
I want to change campaign finance, but right now
the candidate that raises the most money wins and
the candidate that buys TV ads is more likely to
win. We've got to do it. We can't unilaterally
disarm because then we'll just never win. This
is different. This is a principle of engagement
and civic duty and voting. And so I wouldn't feel
OK abandoning it here and saying, yeah, you guys,
it is rigged. You should you should stay home.
Republicans don't vote. I just wouldn't feel good
about it. Others might. And it's a decision you'll
have to make for yourselves. User Brody Mulligan
says if offered to you and available immediately,
would you take Fyssas covid-19 vaccine?
You know, at this point, I would.
Now, based on what I've been seeing,
based on my risk profile and demographic
information, I am not likely to be able to get
a vaccine until April, May or June. As of right
now, if half the country ends up not wanting it,
that that might accelerate and it might be
moved up. At this point, I have seen enough
of the data and Pfizer biotech released detailed
data two days ago about the vaccine that I would
take it. I know that there's roughly a 10 percent
chance that I would have some kind of a reaction,
physical reaction in the arm. I'm not someone
who's had prior allergic reactions to vaccines.
And so that is not a concern to me. And the
data to me would be if if I wasn't taking it
from anybody who needs it more acutely than I do
today, I would take the Pfizer biotech vaccine.
Curious to hear from folks in the audience
where you stand about that. You can join the
discussion and even vote in the poll asking about
the Pfizer vaccine by joining the spreaded. It's
free. I'm not selling you anything. Just join
the community at David Pakman Dotcom. Read it.